hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a Masid a daa center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even more
[Music]
how are you guys doing recently two
Islamic speakers tried to come to the
United Kingdom to do some speaking tours
here in the United Kingdom to see their
followers and their fans and their
people to discuss with them and so on
and so forth Muti M and Muhammad hablas
two very famous and prominent Islamic
speakers across the world and they were
blocked from doing so because of the
following intervention by the media of
all people and not just the media by the
way I should add it was also the far
right media a channel called GB news a
channel characterized by its sentiments
anti-muslim and anti-immigration
sentiments you could even call it and
some have called it racist sentiments
but they have in fact
exposed themselves and exposed the
interplay between thef far right
now and the governments of Western
countries let's take a look at this and
respond in kind as regular viewers will
know my show has revealed that radical
Islamic preachers are on their way to
Britain one of them Muhammad hoblos is
banned in the Netherlands and Germany
for being too extreme he's reportedly
supported violence carried out by Hamas
and urged others to do the same Muffy
manir is the other one he is on record
spouting anti-semitic rhetoric And
discussing stoning adulterers in graphic
detail we sent the home office Miss
loads of video clips of these two
preachers so well this man is Grand
standing his show boating the first
thing I will say is you have prompted me
to look at your content and I found that
you've said some defamatory things about
myself and as such I've instructed legal
counsel to take you to court you're
going to be going to court my friends
just like other people that I have taken
to court as you know I'm a very
litigious man I've taken Douglas Murray
to court I've taken The Spectator to
court there Telegraph to court taking
Tommy Robinson to court taking many
people to court and I've taken people to
court in different
countries and yes there will be a
response because this we have to
understand as Muslim people right and I
know many Muslims are watching this and
I know many non-muslims are watching
this but as Muslim people now we are
under severe attack we are under severe
attack especially after the ascendancy
of the far right and Donald Trump in the
United States of America this is a fact
now there's no question about it we are
under severe attack we are being abused
on many different grounds and look the
irony of this all is that this is meant
to be a channel that talks about freedom
of speech and expression but it seems to
be that the far right wants to allow
freedom of speech and expression to
exist in all things that are
antithetical to its own purposes which
are anti-islamic and or anti-immigrant
purposes in other words your SEL in your
understanding of freedom of speech and
expression why would you want to
celebrate in grandio form
grandstanding form why would you want to
celebrate blocking somebody
who is antithetical has antithetical
belief systems to yours why would you
want to celebrate blocking them from
exercising freedom of speech so long as
they do not call to violence which in
these two case they have not called to
violence and I challenge anyone to find
anything where they're calling to
violence and the reason you're doing
this is because you're
fragile and you're insecure and you're
scared and so Muslim people have to
understand right now we represent
minorities in the Western World we need
to have a
multi-pronged
multifaceted response to individuals
governments whatever it may be that are
trying try to stop us from existing they
are trying to render us into impossible
subjects they are trying to be smch our
reputation and remove our status in
these countries this cannot be the case
and this will not be allowed to be the
case and we will fight this tooth and
nail in every legal
Manner and every legal means possible
Available To Us by any legal means
possible and yes I do have to caveat
that one because of the time that we're
living in and I will say that now I try
myself me and my compatriots and my
friends my companians to travel to some
other Western countries and now we are
finding for example I was meant to go to
Canada and usually I just do the ETA and
I had actually a valid ETA which is an
ETA is the electronic travel authoriz
authorization document I had a valid one
till 2028 then they sent me an email all
of a sudden and they said you have to
produce all this new
information
okay uh this is the information you have
to produce and this and that and the
other you've never done this with me
before but I know why you're doing it
because the news media has had some HIIT
pieces on me taking my statements out of
context just like GB news has done so in
a defamatory manner which shows by the
way that you're weak and you can't
handle our arguments because you have to
misrepresent our positions you're weak
and you cannot handle our arguments
that's why you have to misrepresent our
positions if you are strong enough you
would steal man every single one of our
arguments and try and face those
arguments rather than distort them and
try and block us from speaking in the
first
place this actually does demonstrate
cowardice but the message to take home
now for the Muslim Community is that
things will get worse unfortunately for
us and we have to now prepare all sorts
of consequences we have to prepare all
sorts of consequences of a legal
manner that we can use against these
people that want to take our rights away
and we have to form a civil rights
movement it's actually at that stage we
have reached a stage where we require a
civil a Muslim civil rights movement in
America in Canada in the United Kingdom
in Western Europe everywhere the far
right is on ascendancy and they're
afraid of us not only that they want to
remove us they want to sponge us they
want
to completely rid their societies of us
because they're afraid of us and we have
to respond whether that is legally
institutionally or through
media with that I will
conclude your brothers and sisters in
Islam net from Norway are establishing a
Masid a DA Center this Center this Masid
this education institution will act like
a beacon of light calling the Muslims in
Norway back to the essence of Islam so
give generously and Allah will give you
even more